so today family friendly felix is going
to do some instructional videos
my mission here is to spread the
positive message of
instructional videos instructional
videos i don't know if you've seen them
uh there's some really old ones for
example this one is a guide
to the internet the family guide to
computers twilight zone to star trek yes
[Music]
damn that was tight
and jammies and family remember the
jamison family it's another day in the
last
[ __ ] with my family this is 28 minutes
i'm barely getting started it's a little
bit like yours hi
i want to kill myself and if you're like
us until recently we didn't know what
you're doing
but a few months ago we decided to join
the information age oh i love this so
much i love it so much thank you we'd
like to share with you what our family
has learned about computers well the
first thing you need to do is watch porn
it's really exciting to take the
computer out of the box i'm going for it
[Music]
i recommend that first you make sure all
the parts are there before you start to
get underway that's right and everyone
can help you know they've made it so
much easier than in the old days now
most computer systems are sold with a
lot of software programs already
installed
and the installation of additional
software is made automatic with
microsoft windows 95
[Music]
windows 95
the good old days
if you're lucky your system will have
color-coded cables that enable you to
put your pc [ __ ]
no
god damn how do i plug these in
how am i supposed to go in the
installation of additional software why
was this haircut out of all ungod
forbidden haircuts popular i don't
understand
what do you guys think is it working for
me i feel [ __ ] anime [ __ ] right now
dawg if you're serious about oh my god
not so [ __ ] close you really need to
start out with an understanding of the
basics of your system and how to use
each program
so let's dive right in
[Music]
yes
all because of a computer ship
and my family is a
one of the most basic computer
applications is word processing in the
good old days this was known as typing
and i did a newsletter for girl scouts
complete with pictures that's great
that's great honey
condescending
that's that's come back when you get an
eight even though i work out of the home
professional word processing makes my
company look as big as the others can
you stop touching her it's making me
uncomfortable one program that's
included in many computer bundles is
microsoft works what the [ __ ] is peter
doing
what the
peter what the hell man you you you
weirdo like spell check and cut and
paste make your document look like it
was professionally printed
professionally printed
every time they type they don't know how
to type they miss type word processing
special features like spell check and
cut and paste make your document look
like it was professionally printed
he clicked pace instead of look it's not
even straight
and today many of these applications
come bundled together with other
programs in money-saving packages called
suites and they can represent some real
savings you know anne you get more today
for 250 than you used to get for twice
that amount
[Music]
say you're thinking of opening up a new
business and you want to see if you're
on the road to success you should use a
spreadsheet to plan your budget
do you know what a spreadsheet is peter
no but i know what your mama spreads at
night well the first thing you need to
determine is your system resource
availability oh [ __ ] what's that
that's fancy computer talk for whether
you have enough processing power disk
space and memory to handle the
application you're gonna run
just look at everyone they have no idea
what the [ __ ] is going on it's so
beautiful with today's more powerful
programs they do require a lot more
memory and storage i still remember back
in the old days of computers when 40
megabytes was a lot
geez dad that's ancient history geez dad
that's ancient history get on my level
[ __ ] i got a 600 megabyte ram with a
200 gigahertz processor that will
[ __ ] fat your ass up dog it's hella
tight did you have black and white
televisions back then too
he got black and white display on that
[ __ ]
to install a suite of office
applications you use the same type of
installation process as for most other
programs okay what is it what is it what
is it you click on my computer okay then
select add and remove programs okay then
click ahead to install the application
from your cd or disk simply select your
default locations most of the time did
they say delete system32 is that what
i'm supposed to ah
to reboot you simply choose yes if the
computer asks you whether to turn itself
off and then on again
that seems a little too complicated it's
the way the computer gets started with
your program
but what if you're still having trouble
then you're [ __ ] [ __ ] here are
some applications that can bring hours
of enjoyment to every member of the
family
it's called graphics programs graphics
graphics
graphics programs chance to be really
creative by using the computer to help
you draw and paint digitally whoa i love
graphics on the computer whoa
dude that's some [ __ ] psychedelic
[ __ ] i prepared this club newsletter
last month using microsoft publisher and
there are other great home graphic
software programs out there too tell
them how you did it everyone was so
impressed by how professional it looked
please dad tell us a secret everyone was
like dawg
dude this is the sickest broken document
i've ever seen
dad please i even helped my sister
create a new resume when she was looking
for a job
isn't she uh still out of work
what the [ __ ] what are they hinting at
here what does that mean
she
look at peter peter always has the best
face depending on the application you'll
have
how what who looks at someone like that
i'm sorry
that's right [ __ ] tell them about the
graphic computer program
[Music]
one of the most popular programs for
home computers is money management after
all aren't most of us perplexed about
where all the money goes
it's one of the things i like best now
that i've become a computer whiz
oh my god the cringe oh my god the
cringe my god the cringe oh my god oh my
god unfortunately viruses and our
computers are as real as viruses in our
families
oh my god kill me
kill me the mom needs to go okay the mom
needs to go this is some tyra banks
level of comedy mate
[Music]
how often do we actually have to back
things up at school they told us we
should do it every few minutes that's it
jesus
back it up it's been a few minutes back
up
back up
back up when you're losing minutes here
precious minutes
[Music]
you know dad almost all the cool stuff
for computers these days comes on
cd-roms games shareware
multimedia yes i became better in math
because i used mighty math calculating
crew when i was only three
when you were only three you were
playing this computer game
sure buddy
sure i do think that a little
information on how to set up the new
color printer would be helpful though i
agree how about you pete
[Music]
farewell oh no
don't go
yeah come on let peter tell us about
small computer programs
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
twilight zone to star trek hardware
software take a
[Music]
yeah great all right i hope you enjoyed
this let me know if you want me to do
more i'll leave a like and uh yeah i
hope you hope you enjoy it
as always stay awesome i mean
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]